let's try it's okay let's try no
pressure fun
[Laughter]
listen this is the matrix master here no
that's not true but okay
what are the rules like this is is there
a buzzer no
i don't want it to be a contest
that's the only answer that i know for
sure so i'm gonna definitely have to
confirm no pressure
what is it d
b
is that the felt i felt something at
least you're feeling something i'm blank
the neuromancer you had a gut inside
yeah like but the hairs on my on my arm
they say stood up d c malacca in
simulation
[Music]
i knew it i knew i kind of knew that too
i kind of knew that right
now
that was my second choice this arm was
like what are you saying this one was
like hey this one's like no i actually
knew them all before you did that
[Music]
three or three
oh my god i don't remember that one it's
uh room 101 yeah i'm not gonna say
nothing no it's obviously not six six i
don't know why three or three jumped out
of my box was it your left hand or your
right hand it was the right hand
wow keanu knew that juan is keanu and
one is trinity and the o is bringing
them back together in a cycle of life
303 when you turn it sideways
mom mom
what was your point
i think it's a 303
it's 303 it's right oh my god i went to
1984. i knew it i quit you can't
okay i lost all my points
[Music]
know thyself no that's not myself i
think it's c
know thyself
yeah i knew it
oh my god oh god temit no
okay we're getting into the groove of it
now guys okay i just had to get a
recovery i gotta get it okay so what are
the choices
i have pills for you
i think i got he said i got pills
hello i have films i have pills for you
none of them
hey
lost it's not lost well he's on the
phone in the cubicle right i believe
right he's in the cubicle and he's like
who is this hello neo
yeah so that sequence was the first day
of filming on the matrix was in the
office and it's when agent smith is
coming in the wachowskis were working
with the steadicam that day because they
had a lot of shots to make and i
remember it was at the end of the day
and they were walking away i was walking
behind them and they were both walking
and they without even looking at each
other they just went
[Laughter]
gave each other like a low high five
that's dope and i was just like right on
yeah that's dope yeah like we made our
day we made our day we did it we did it
it's cool we got this
dodge this
oh dodge this
dodge this does this
[Music]
no that one i really knew okay do it do
it do it do it do it go ahead do it only
human
dodge this
it's definitely not the anxiety pill
trace program
logically if you think about it a
reality pill i think it's a trace
program so that they can get you to
reality
it's a trace program yeah of course oh
i mean yeah right
i can't believe it
you